the stock market plummets as president
from trade war with China bites
president Trump cracks down on Venezuela
and America continues to divide over
mass shootings I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show are you got a lot
to get to today a lot happening in the
news so we're just going to jump right
in the big controversy in the aftermath
of the mass shootings that happened over
the weekend one of course happening in
Dayton Ohio the other happening now Paso
Texas the big controversy has broken out
over El Paso and Dayton and politics
obviously because it would be too much
to ask that we all be on the same page
white supremacy evil white supremacist
terrorism evil and should be fought like
terrorism mass shootings horrific and we
should discuss possible solutions like
that would all be too reasonable and too
rational instead there's a narrative and
the narrative that's being developed by
the media and by a lot of folks on the
left is that President Trump is solely
responsible for what happened in El Paso
and that the right is complicit in this
and that all conservatives are secretly
white supremacist now I think there are
some folks on the Left I don't want to
lump the entire life together here I
think there's some folks on the Left who
are being a little bit more careful
about all this I think there are certain
folks on the Left who are intellectually
honest enough to acknowledge that
mainstream conservatives are
extraordinarily upset about white
supremacists to terrorism that some of
us have spent our careers fighting white
supremacism that some of us have
incurred hundreds of thousands of
dollars in payments that we have to make
to security because of our fight against
white supremacism some people are
careful about this other people however
and this includes many in the mainstream
media are attempting to develop a
narrative and when you're attempting to
develop a narrative any fact that
doesn't fit the narrative can be dealt
with in one of two ways
either you can incorporate it into a new
narrative that is more nuanced and more
interesting and more relevant and that
follows the world of fact better or you
can simply discard the fact and pretend
that the fact doesn't exist and it's
pretty obvious today that there are a
lot of folks in the media who are more
interested in the second path who are
very upset in fact when the media
accidentally stumbled into Jareau into
doing journalism when other members of
the media stumble into doing journalism
they get very upset with them because
those acts of journalism might undercut
the narrative that so many members of
the left are trying to build so as we
know the members of the left
trying to build a narrative that
narrative is that President Trump is
responsible for El Paso the Trump is a
white nationalist that anyone who
supports Trump is by default in white
nationalist as well or a white
nationalist sympathizer that folks on
the right are broadly speaking
responsible for the evil of what just
happened in El Paso Texas that is the
narrative that folks on the Left are
attempting to push and it's a really
ugly narrative it's an extraordinarily
ugly narrative it happens to be an
extraordinarily false narrative and yet
this is increasingly the narrative that
is being pushed by the left and so what
you see is folks like David Leonhardt
writing over at the New York Times
conservatism has a violence problem the
numbers don't lie
he says American conservatism has a
violence problem the current Secretary
of Energy Rick Perry once publicly
suggested that the chairman of the
Federal Reserve deserve to be beaten up
because of his interest rate policy
bread Jim Forte a member of Congress
from Montana physically assaulted a
reporter who asked him a question he
didn't like President Trump has
repeatedly alluded to extrajudicial
physical force including suggesting that
his supporters might resort to violence
if they didn't get their way the most
extreme version of conservatism violence
problem is the most tragic the pattern
of mass shootings by people espousing
right-wing views sometimes encouraged in
online forums okay that is not part of
conservatism violence problem because
there is not a single conservative
living in the United States who believes
that the shooting of innocence is a
solution to the nation's problems
nothing about conservatism which is
about government protection of life
liberty and property nothing in
conservatism which is about the belief
that Western civilization has created a
forum for democracy and liberalism and
free markets nothing there espouses
either a race-based view of the world or
the idea that you should be able to go
out and hurt people whom you dislike
particularly on the basis of race and
yet David leonhardt is pushing the idea
that this is a mere extension of the
right-wing tendency toward violence and
this is nonsense of course and if we're
gonna talk about politicians who are
espousing violence all you have to do to
find politicians who espouse violence is
go on Twitter today where Barbara Boxer
was joking about Mitch McConnell falling
down and breaking his shoulder all you
have to do is take a look at cory booker
suggesting a couple of weeks ago
that you'd like to punch Donald Trump in
the face Joe Biden has said very similar
things politicians on all side of the
aisle have been using the sort of
language for decades so the fact that
there are certain Republicans who have
done it does not mean this is an
exclusively right-wing problem also
David Leonhardt then cites a study from
the ADL it's very not it's a very skewed
study says 39 of the 50 killings
committed by political extremists
according to the ADL were carried out by
white supremacist another eight were
committed by killers with
anti-government views okay that ADL
study does not actually look to be
rationale behind the killings it simply
suggests that white supremacist have
committed a certain number of killings
and that is true but as we will see that
is not the standard to which the Left
holds itself so here it should be the
standard for political killings a
political killing is when it is
politically motivated right now that I
think is a reasonable standard for a
political killing a political killing is
not when somebody commits a killing and
then we go and we look into their
politics in sort of a backfilled fashion
and then a tribute to their politics
what may not have been political a lot
of the killings by white supremacist
when family members or other white
supremacist for example and then to
attribute that more broadly to
conservatism is a second-order mistake
that David Leonhardt makes over at the
New York Times John and Jonathan
Greenblatt head of the ADL says
right-wing extremist violence is our
biggest threat the numbers don't lie I
may agree that it's our biggest threat
but to associate that with conservatism
more generally is despicable it's even
David Lee and heart says yes I
understand there are important caveats
to add conservative America is mostly
filled with honorable people who deplore
violence and bear no responsibility for
right-wing hate killings some mass
shootings have no evident political
motive like the one in Dayton Ohio on
Sunday and liberal America also has
violent ends arranged people like the
man who shot and Republican members of
Congress playing softball in 2017 some
Democratic politicians have also
occasionally lapsed into ugly violent
rhetoric and suggested they want to
punch their political opponents but it's
folly to pretend that the problem is
symmetrical mainstream conservative
politicians use the rhetoric of physical
violence much more often starting with
the current President of the United
States any stats to prove this by the
way we have a comprehensive statistical
analysis of this I'd be curious to find
out whether that is the case or not in
any case this is the narrative that is
being pushed
and that narrative is being tied
specifically to president from because
Trump uses inflammatory language on a
regular basis uses language that I think
crosses a lot of lines of decency on a
regular basis since the idea is you pin
white supremacist killings that Trump is
not responsible for on Trump and then
you pin Trump on the right and thus the
generalized right conservatives across
America are responsible for killings
that they deplore hate will it have
nothing to do with condemn believe that
the person who did you get the death
penalty for it's a really easy trick and
despicable trick that the left is
playing is we'll see when that trick is
challenged in any way the folks on the
Left can't abide it like in any way and
this is the trick as I'll explain in
just one second first let's talk about
hiring at your business so you want to
upgrade your business you want to make
sure that everybody at your business is
top-quality
well hiring used to be hard not anymore
when someone makes the slightest most
minor insignificant mistake here on the
bench Shapiro show they know how easily
we can replace them and they live in
fear of that day and that sort of fear
makes them work harder see the beatings
will continue until morale improves here
at the Daily wire in reality we're just
hiring we're not really firing anybody
we don't have a habit of firing people
because we hired them people from the
beginning because we use it recruiter
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter will send your job posting to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter an equality candidate through
the site within the very first day right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruit comm slash daily wire that's
zip recruit comm slash at Dai ly
WI re zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now that is zip recruiter comm
slash daily wear so as I say it's not
just David Leonhart it is also another
New York Times columnist named Jamelle
Bouie Jamelle Bouie
writes about race all the time and
believes that virtually everything he
disagrees with is evidence of racism so
Jamelle Bouie attacked me yesterday
personally i tweeted out that I thought
it was despicable that so many folks in
the press we're trying to conflate
conservatism more generally with white
supremacism that we hate right some of
us as I say I've had in
normos number of death threats some of
us have been the victims of white
supremacist who are currently going to
prison because of those death threats
and so I wrote yesterday about some
folks on the left your conflation of all
conservatives with white supremacist
monsters who despise actual conservative
principles you know like the universal
non racially based applicability of
principles of Western civilization is
cynical deliberate and disgusting so
Jamelle Bouie jumps right into that hole
and immediately does exactly what i
accused him of doing he says the real
point of this tantrum is to go after
anyone who makes might make the
connection between white nationalism and
ben's ideological project you see my
ideological project is connected to
white nationalism in forwarding the
aspirations of white nationalism
according to Jamelle Bouie never mind
the fact that I have been the loudest
critic of white nationalism probably in
the United States for the last four
years and was their number one target in
2016 that doesn't matter I'm apparently
one of them or at least I'm lending them
credibility or I'm connected to their
viewpoint is according to a columnist
for The New York Times and more broadly
the left is trying to do this with with
President Trump and they're trying to
suggest that Trump is the one who is
lending credence to white nationalists
now I said at the time in 2015 and 2016
that Trump went and nodded at the
outright that was true he did do that in
2015 and 2016 it was wrong it was
morally reprehensible I said it at the
time but since 2017 he has not been
doing this up now maybe that's reason
but the fact is so are these shootings
if these shootings are recent - and to
blame them on Trump who has come out
repeatedly and condemned white national
it wasn't you be happy if he condemned
white nationalism well he did yesterday
and it turns out he's been doing it
repeatedly in fact we have this mashup
of President Trump over the last two
years condemning white nationalism about
a thousand times in row there must be no
tolerance for anti-semitism in America
or for any form of religious or racial
hatred we are a country that stands
united in condemning hate and evil in
all of its very ugly forms we want our
country to be a place where every child
from every background can grow up free
from fear innocent of hatred and
surrounded by love opportunity
hope racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals and
thugs including the KKK neo-nazis white
supremacist and other hate groups that
are repugnant to everything we hold dear
as Americans those who spread violence
in the name of bigotry strike at the
very core of America we must never
ignore the vile poison of anti-semitism
or those who spread its venomous Creed
with one voice we must confront this
hatred anywhere and everywhere it occurs
ok Trump has said all this stuff the
left doesn't like that he said all this
stuff because it fights against the
narrative that they are trying to paint
the narrative being that Trump is the
cause of white supremacism in the United
States even though it obviously precedes
him there been white supremacist
shootings in the United States going all
the way back to my childhood and beyond
I remember there was a white supremacist
shooting in my neighborhood back in 1999
there's a white supremacist who drove
right past the place where I was about
to go to high school and then proceeded
to go to the West Valley JCC and shoot
up the West Valley JCC there were white
supremacists shootings during Barack
Obama's tenure he said this precedes
Trump now you may make the case that it
is worse under President Trump I think
statistically it's unclear whether that
is the case but in my opinion it is in
my opinion that is the case but the
attempt to paint Trump as a white
nationalist or white supremacist is
obviously the goal here and it is
politically motivated because now Trump
is speaking out on the same stuff you
want him to speak out on and you're
angry about it you're mad at me
shouldn't you be happy that Trump is now
swiveling around on this
shouldn't you be encouraging him to do
this you know all of the editorials over
the weekend where Trump needs to speak
out about white nationalism then he
speaks out about white nationalism and
white supremacy and everybody on the
Left object because it turns out the
real agenda isn't to have from say the
right thing it's to have Trump say the
wrong thing so that you can then
browbeat conservatives with the idea
that they are supporters of white
supremacy every Democratic presidential
candidate has been pushing this
particular narrative hey Joe Biden
yesterday compared Trump to the KKK hey
the you can say a lot of things about
Trump Trump is not a member of the KKK
that's absurd this is a president who
said things no other president has said
since Andrew Jackson we went through
this before and in the in the 20s with
the Ku Klux Klan 50,000 people walking
down Pennsylvania Avenue in pointed hats
and their robes because they in fact
decided they didn't want any Catholics
coming into the country we went through
it after the Civil War in terms of the
Ku Klux Klan and white supremacy this is
about separating people and the good and
bad in his mind it's a trait used by
charlatans all over the world divide
people divide them put them against one
another I'm sorry it is it is
unbelievable to hear this coming from
Joe Biden who suggested that Republicans
like Mitt Romney the most milquetoast
human being who has ever walked the
earth want to put black people back in
Chains then we heard Joe Biden talking
about folks who are dividing people
along racial lines a beta O'Rourke then
suggested that President Trump shouldn't
come to El Paso of course because he is
the great adjudicator of who should come
to El Paso including the elected
president of the United States who by
the way won the state of Texas in 2016
don't think the president should come
here why he described Mexican immigrants
this is a town of Mexican immigrants as
rapists and criminals repeatedly has
warned of an invasion trying to make us
afraid of those who do not look like the
majority of this country he's described
human beings as an infestation you only
have an attack like this when you have a
president who gives people permission to
act on this hatred and it's racism and
so that's standard if we're gonna hold
that standard then Barack Obama Dallas
police officer shooting Ferguson riots
Baltimore riots Bernie Sanders shooting
aoc ice detainment facility attack I
mean it's very easy to extend the
standard that her work is talking about
to encompass pretty much all political
rhetoric in the United States you can
see that the media are very unhappy that
Trump condemned white supremacy
yesterday they're they're interested in
the division not in unification Don
Lemon is a great example of this Don
Lemon on CNN he suggested yesterday that
Trump even condemning white supremacy
rings hollow so how would it not ring
hollow exactly well yeah I mean really
you have to ask the councilor a question
which is you have to give me how would
it not ring hollow what would he say
that wouldn't ring hollow to Don Lemon
the answer is nothing
and as we'll see the left is very upset
that anybody would point out that Trump
actually condemned way too
yesterday we have also called on this
president to say the words that he
finally said today but they ring hollow
when he cuddles white-supremacist or
domestic terrorism or those who perform
those acts so listen I hope that this
makes a difference but how many times
have you and I been sitting here on
television saying well I hope this one
changes things I hope this one changes
things and then nothing happens
okay so again that's not journalism that
is opinion and Don Lemon is supposed to
be journalism a well the journalism got
all over the place during that
particular segment we'll get to more of
this in just one time we'll talk about
the agenda again the agenda is to say
that Trump is in fact the cause of white
supremacist terror attacks across the
United States and then to tie
conservatives more generally to Trump
and by extension to white supremacist
terror attacks across the United States
instead of us unifying there's a
deliberate attempt being made to divide
Americans when we all agree on this
stuff that's the dirty secret we all
agree white supremacism evil evil
disgusting evil that cancer should be
like we're all on the same page we
should all be mourning together today
you should all be coming up with
solutions together today instead the
left is insistent that the right swallow
the white supremacist terror attack as a
natural consequence of conservatism well
mo the answer is no I'm not gonna do
that because it's bullcrap that's not a
thing that's going to happen look at
some more of this in just one second
first losing hair is no fun two out of
three dudes are going to experience hair
loss by the time they are 35 I know that
hair loss runs in my family I greatly
fear it introducing keeps the easiest
most affordable way to keep the hair
that you have these fda-approved
products they used to cost a lot of
money but now thanks to keeps they're
finally inexpensive they are easy to
obtain for five minutes now starting at
just 10 bucks per month you're not gonna
have to worry about hair loss again
which sounds pretty fantastic getting
started is really easy signing up takes
less than five minutes just answer a few
simple questions snap some photos to
complete your online doctor consultation
a licensed physician will review your
information online recommend the right
treatment for you and it shipped
directly to your door every three months
keeps treatments are up to 90% effective
at reducing and stopping for their hair
loss it's not like it's gonna regrow new
hair it's gonna stop the hair loss in
place which is big for me it's the
reason why
I have used keeps because as I say male
pattern baldness it runs in my family
not something I am interested in
participating in only 10 bucks to 35
bucks a month plus now you can get your
first month for free which is a hell of
a deal forgetting to keep your hair if
you suffer from hair loss or if it runs
in your family the last thing you need
is to wait to see a doctor you need to
get this done now go to keeps calm slash
bend and receive your first month of
treatment for free that's keeps calm /
Ben again if you suffer from hair loss
receive that first month of treatment
for free that's ke EPS calm / Ben okay
so Joe Scarborough made the connection
complete yesterday when he suggested on
his show that anybody who supports
President Trump is by necessity
supporting white supremacist terror
attacks for those of you who are funding
donald trump's reelection campaign you
may want to take note that because you
keep writing checks to this president
it's on you it really is it's all on you
because you were funding this white
supremacist campaign ceos you really are
businesspeople millionaires and
billionaires it's your money that is
funding this white supremacy because you
won't tell him to stop who's not telling
him to stop when he said all the bad
stuff that he said in the past i'm
pretty sure a lot of people were telling
him to stop and by the way if you
support Trump in his re-election bid
because you don't trust Kamala Harris or
Elizabeth Warren or Joe Biden around the
country this does not make you a white
supremacist the attempt to tie politics
to this event is a deliberate attempt to
elect a Democrat to the White House
that's what this is about and here's how
you can tell
so today the media actually started to
cover this thing the way they should
cover it so the New York Times yesterday
ran a ridiculous and bizarre headline
they're ridiculous and bizarre headline
which I pointed out yesterday was
something to the effect of Donald Trump
condemns racism but says nothing about
guns and as I pointed out that is not
actually a here's the exact headline it
was Trump condemns white supremacy but
doesn't propose gun laws after shooting
and as I pointed out that's not
journalism right that is the New York
Times saying what they wish he had said
not what he said what he actually said
was that white supremacy is evil
wouldn't that be the headline Trump
white supremacy is evil a very easy a
headline to write
Trump condemns
supremacy that's where the headline ends
okay so I pointed that out yesterday
well apparently the editors at the New
York Times actually got the message and
so they're a headline on the front page
of the New York Times today was quote
Trump urges unity versus racism Trump
urges unity versus racism that is a
factually true headline and now you may
think that it's disingenuous you may
think that as Don Lemon does that it
rings hollow but the actual headline if
you are a news person is that Trump
urges unity versus racism and it's not
by his headline that is a very
straightforward headline the entire left
went insane mate O'Rourke came out and
said it was disgusting the New York
Times had run that headline Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez as is her want accused the
New York Times of white supremacism so I
guess it was Nancy Pelosi three weeks
ago now it's the New York Times pushing
white supremacism apparently Nate Silver
who is at 5:38 nas obviously is of the
political left said not sure Trump urges
unity versus racism so I put that back
up for a second Nate Silver said not
sure Trump urges unity versus racism is
how I would have framed the story and
then aosc says let this front page serve
as a reminder of how white supremacy is
aided by and often relies upon the
cowardice of mainstream institutions we
remember that time that Trump called the
New York Times fake news and everybody
was like oh my god that right there is
an attack on the First Amendment it's an
attack on the press when a OC says that
the New York Times is forwarding white
supremacy I guess that's not an attack
on the press because it's a yo scene we
all love a OC right I mean she is the
wisest most benevolent most beautiful
among us the most brilliant thus when
she rips into the New York Times as an
institution of white supremacy filled
with cowardice not a problem at all so
what did the New York Times do the New
York Times switched its front page not
kidding because of blowback from the
left because well because many on the
Left were suggesting they were gonna
cancel their subscriptions over the
headline the factually accurate headline
the New York Times it reversed itself
and pulled down that headline and put up
a new headline the headline was
assailing hate but not guns now
that is not in fact if it's not actually
a factual headline the president
actually called for certain gun
regulations including red flag
Galatians that is editorializing right
but not Blanc is not a factual reportage
decision that is an editorializing
decision right that's the kind of
headline that I could write after every
Barack Obama speech Barack Obama
endorses X but not YY being a thing I
wanted him to endorse right that's
editorializing so the New York Times a
paper that used to be found it used to
be their slogan their slogan used to be
without fear or favor right that it was
a it was a statement made by the founder
of the New York Times bout a hundred
years ago without fear or favor well
forget that now it's fear of the left
means that we will favor the left so
they're gonna switch the headline why
because it would undercut the narrative
that the left is attempting to drive if
Trump actually did urge unity versus
racism it's amazing and speaking of
upholding the leftist narrative speaking
of upholding that leftist narrative the
CNN ran a piece today and the piece was
about the politics of the Dayton Ohio
shooter now a couple of things can be
true one the Dayton Ohio shooter was not
overtly political in his shooting
meaning he'd not released a manifesto
and say here is why I'm committing this
act of evil right as the el paso shooter
did and that is a valid distinction
because to treat them as equally
politically motivated in the absence of
evidence that the Dayton shooting was
politically motivated would be dishonest
however are we going to pretend that if
the El Paso shooting had happened and
there were no manifesto and then it
turns out that the guy's social media
postings were littered with white
supremacists disgusting trash or Trump
endorsements that that wouldn't have
been first and foremost in the media
coverage are we really gonna pretend
that's how this works
so CNN runs a piece and I'll explain in
just a second what the piece says and
the left loses its mind how dare CNN
cover actual movies how dare they do it
it undercuts the narrative we'll get to
that in just one second first how about
something that we can all agree on at
least until the left decides we can't
agree on it
saving money honey it's a free tool that
you download to your computer's browser
well you shop online honey scans the
internet for coupon codes and other
discounts and then it automatically
applies the coupon with the biggest
savings to your cart at checkout just
like magic so you might ask how do I
know that honey has my back well because
they've saved me probably hundreds of
dollars at this point given the fact
that I have honey
in the background of my computer every
time I shop anywhere from Amazon to
Walmart to Costco there are honey
discounts that are going to be applied
so long as they can be found not only
did honey test over 1 billion promo
codes last year it actually applied 185
million 67,000 86 working codes to
people's orders that is a lot of real
life savings all you do and again you
don't have to think about whether
they're gonna cover a particular site
upon which you shop you just let it run
in the background of your computer and
if they can save you money
they will there's really no reason not
to use honey it's free to use it's easy
to install on your computer in just two
clicks don't overthink that promo box
ever again
get honey for free at join honey calm
slash pen that's it join honey calm
slash been honey online savings
simplified okay so the CNN runs this
piece and the piece talks about the
politics of the person who is
responsible of the shooter in Dayton
Ohio and this apparently is very very
bad very bad
you're not allowed to talk about his
politics the left goes nuts why is CNN
even running a story about the politics
of the Dayton Ohio shooter we don't even
know that the shooting was politically
motivated right number one we don't know
that it wasn't politically motivated but
also necessary to note that if we're now
gonna hold to the standard that only
politically motivated shootings ought to
be covered in a political way I'm all
for that standard now you're gonna have
to go back in time and undo what you did
with Gabby Giffords and Sarah Palin
where you attributed the shooting of
Gabby Giffords by an insane person to
Sarah Palin saying that Gabby Giffords
shouldn't be reelected with a mat with a
target map of her face okay you guys are
gonna have to undo the whole routine
where you suggested that the Orlando
pulse nightclub shooting was a result of
Republican homophobia you're gonna have
to undo all that stuff because it seems
to me that every time somebody does
something you don't like you go and dig
up their political profile and then you
attempt to link it to broader right wing
right wing concerns so if this is the
new standard then have at it guys I feel
like that's a better standard but if the
standard right now is that we don't know
number one whether this was political or
not or number two we're gonna hold by
your usual standard which is we dig up
the politics of a person who did
something evil and then in tribute to
everybody else who holds any of those
political stances the
of this person and then you guys are
gonna have to deal with the fact that
this particular Dayton shooter was an
Elizabeth Warren supporter who was
openly socialist who was a far left kook
a Twitter account according to CNN that
appears to belong to Dayton mass shooter
I'm not gonna say his name retweeted
extreme left-wing and anti police posts
as well as tweets supporting an Tifa or
anti-fascist protesters the most recent
tweet of the account was on August 3rd
the day of the shooting he retweeted a
post saying Millennials have a message
for the Joe Biden generation hurry up
and die police don't know what motivated
this person it is also true that as
politics are far left it is obvious that
his politics are far left in the hours
before the Dayton shooting the Twitter
account liked several tweets about the
shooting in El Paso including one
supporting gun control and other that's
they called the El Paso shooting suspect
two terrorists and a white supremacist
the account retweeted messages
supporting a Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren as well as post against
ice agents including one that said these
people are monsters and multiple posts
condemning police and supporting Antipa
protesters who often use violent tactics
okay so apparently it's very bad for CNN
to report this Kellyanne Conway tweeted
out the CNN piece and she was
immediately accused of doing something
evil for tweeting out the CNN piece
pretty astonishing prettiest I mean this
this is our great journalist they're
telling us not only what we should cover
but what we should not cover so we
shouldn't cover this stuff why because
of the person's political convictions
now as I said two things can be true at
once one we don't know that his politics
drove the shooting and thus it shouldn't
be covered in the same way up El Paso
and two if this person we're on the
right it would be covered exactly the
same way as El Paso by the media because
that is what our media do the bravest
and finest among us because
unfortunately it doesn't back their
narrative that violence is associated
solely with the right anything that
doesn't fit with that narrative has to
be ignored by the media which is of
course why it wasn't a national news
story when a person quoting aoc attacked
a nice detainment facility like two
weeks ago it's why the Bernie Sanders
congressional baseball is shooting the
supporter of Bernie Sanders who did that
that's why that was out in the news
inside of a week and it's why we are
still not seeing any coverage today
of for example fire left protesters at
Mitch McConnell's house who were
standing outside shouting massacre Mitch
McConnell it really had a Miss massacre
Mitch here's some of the video from
outside Mitch McConnell's house Mitch
McConnell was home by the way because he
broke his shoulder it's why nobody on
the Left will cover the fact that so
many members of the left are celebrity
worried about the fact that Rand Paul
was injured by his neighbor a year ago
in some sort of dispute Rand Paul
tweeted out recently that he's not able
to perform his for congressional duties
because he has to have a piece of his
lung removed you should see the replies
to the tweet all from members of the
left talking about why he deserves it
here's some of the video outside Mitch
McConnell's house last night prayers
Mitch we can't even call white men
terrorists they've been terrorists since
the beginning of this gun country you
are terrorists Mitch
you your momma now again I'm not
going to attribute this to the entire
left because this isn't the entire left
but this is a person of the left and a
group of the left who are outside Mitch
McConnell's house with signs that say
hashtag Massacre Mitch that trended on
Twitter yesterday while jihad Ali who is
a CNN commentator in New York Times
contributor he tweeted out hashtag
massacre Moscow Mitch is trending I
still have faith in America then he
deleted it obviously so it's again the
this sort of notion that the political
rhetoric on one side is driving the
great divide in our country is insipid
yes Donald Trump makes our political
rhetoric worse and has been doing so for
several years and yes Democrats also
have been doing this for a long time but
to attribute white supremacist shootings
to the right is no more honest than to
attribute the shooting in Dayton Ohio to
the left more broadly okay that is it's
a particular narrative and the fact that
the the left is now trying to undermine
and it will really underscore the
narrative of their choice by cracking
down on
members of the media who are pointing
out facts that do not align with that
trend is pretty obvious evidence of what
exactly so many folks on the Left are
trying to do now just a second we're
gonna talk about some of the gun control
measures that folks on the Left are
talking about then we want to get to the
trade war with China which is obviously
a massive issue and is going to impact
your life the economy could see a severe
downturn if this sort of stuff continues
first we need to go you're going to need
to go over to daily wire comment
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire comm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get two additional hours of the
show every single day when you get to
$99 a year subscription you get this the
leftist year's hot or cold tumbler it is
magnificent it is also jocular for those
you don't know what a joke is go check
us out over at daily wire con please
subscribe it helps insulate us from the
evil of a left that wishes to censor all
of their opponents by lumping us in with
some of the most evil people on earth
you're not those people you're a you're
a good person who supports conservative
ideals or at least free conversation if
you're not a conservative please go
subscribe of our daily wire com we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so in the aftermath of this mass
shooting obviously Democrats are talking
about their gun control proposals it is
amazing how so many of the folks in the
media are going to members of the left
as though it is the responsibility of
members of the left members of the
Democratic Party to grant absolution to
President Trump for the El Paso shooting
which assumes number one that Trump is
responsible for the El Paso shooting
which is not true and two assumes that
Democrats are in any sort of moral
position to grant absolution for Trump's
rhetoric for the for what happened in El
Paso or anything like that give you an
example Chris Matthews everybody say
well in here Harrell messed up like now
weird very upset about what happened
over the weekend time Tamara Harris
Carla Harris who supports al Sharpton
Carla Harris but things how Sharpton is
a wonderful guy a guy who helped
allegedly inside two riots in New York
City Here I am
Kentucky combo Harris and well have left
Pope Pamela about whether she can
exonerate Trump of these charges he does
things that cause bad behaviors and in
this case his kinds of words encouraged
the kind of action that we've seen in El
Paso is the educable
a typical edgy cabal can he be educated
will this educate him he said to pull
back on it pull back you're he's not
edgy cabal he can't you know my Angela
Maya Angelou took us told us a long time
ago people tell you who they are the
first time believe it he has told us who
he is is the edgy cabal can we teach him
it's like vegetables as you could
prevent you to pose good mathematics tea
tell me about Tomlin can we can we teach
him about Rick tell me more about how
Sharpton Camilla so what exactly are
these Democrats going to do with their
newfound moral bravado what are they
going to do well according to both
Elizabeth Warren and Kamala Harris
they're just going to cram down on the
American people what they want Sun gun
control now if you're on the right and
you say well I'm never gonna vote these
people into office because hey they're
going to cram down gun control on me
according to the left this makes you a
white supremacist because obviously
you'd have to support Trump in order to
defeat Elizabeth Warren or khamel Harris
here's Elizabeth Warren declaring that
the Second Amendment no longer supply
because no longer apply
because tyranny we've seen this sort of
escalation and horrible shooting after
horrible shooting what would you be able
to do as president that's different from
the track record that we've seen on the
first day that I'm president the
Republicans want to try to block things
then we get rid of the filibuster and we
go with the majority vote I will do
everything I can by executive order but
I will also lead on the argument of
getting rid of the filibuster so that by
a majority we can do what the American
people have sent us there to do okay so
she's not actually gonna propose a
policy but she is going to say that she
will do it alone from the top of the
federal government Kamala Harris does
the exact same thing she says she's
gonna use executive action they still
haven't made a national proposal by the
way they're just explaining how they're
going to seize power that is not
delegated to them under the Constitution
is there any other action you're
considering when you look at these for
example two most recent mass shootings
that unfortunately tragically sadly
there have been so many of them in
recent years right so under the Harris
administration I will give the United
States Congress 100 days to pull their
act together on this and put a bill on
my desk for signature and if they do not
I will take executive action as you
mentioned and in particular put in place
a comprehensive background check
requirement I'll also make sure that we
give the ATF the resources that it needs
to take the licenses of gun dealers who
violate the law okay so again there she
is explaining that she is going to just
violate the Constitution wholesale right
they have a hundred days to do something
I want otherwise I'm just gonna do it
myself which of course is what it says
in article 1 of the Constitution when it
grants legislative power to the
president so long as the president can't
get Congress to do what they want what
Democrats actually want Bader
work-release pilled that he was on with
John Favreau
on pod save America and he explained
that what he actually wants is just gun
confiscation broad scale across the
nation I'm sure this is gonna go great
the most effective gun control measures
have been gun licenses and mandatory
buyback programs like they did in
Australia would you be open to those
proposals as president yes and I'm open
to them right now
as a candidate absolutely has to be part
of the conversation and if at the end of
the day it's gonna save lives if it's
prevents the kind of tragedies that we
saw you know Paso or Gilroy or Dayton or
this weekend in Chicago or all over this
country on a daily basis then let's move
forward and do it I there it is so he's
just going to look for a nossa when he
says gun buyback in Australia was a
mandatory buyback meaning that it was
gun confiscation by the way worthy of
note Australia had pretty much no mass
shootings before they had the gun
confiscation and in terms of the murder
rate the gun murder rate in Australia
declined slower than the United States
murder rate from guns at the same exact
same exact period while the number of
guns in circulation in the United States
rose dramatically so none of this
actually matches up but you wonder why
the right is uncomfortable with less
policy prescriptions because you guys
keep saying you're gonna grab our guns
and they're like no no why do you keep
saying them cuz you keep saying you're
gonna grab our guns that would be the
reason right there okay in other news
and what will ends up being very
consequential news for 2020 what we are
looking at right now in the stock market
what we're looking at in the markets
more broadly is fairly disastrous the
market seems to have stabilized a little
bit today in the aftermath of a massive
drop-off over the past week in the stock
market the stock market dropped from
about 27,000 300 about a week ago all
the way down to a low of twenty five
thousand seven hundred to drop about
sixteen hundred points over the course
of a week and that was largely due to
fears of a trade war between the United
States and China and that's because a
bunch of different measures are now
being taken both by the United States
and by the Chinese as this trade war
escalates yesterday the Dow had blench
had plunged 760 points it was the worst
day of 2019 the yield curve inverted the
the bond yields went all the way down to
the very bottom of the deck because
everybody started rushing to buy bonds
because they were afraid of the upcoming
downturn in the economy possibly the
Nasdaq fell for a sixth straight session
the S&P 500 also posted a long six day
losing streak tech stocks were
particularly hard hit that's because
China which has historically controlled
its currency the yuan allowed it to fall
to its low
level on Monday against the dollar in
more than a decade the onshore yuan
broke above seven per US dollar and
traded around 7.05 that's been seen
typically as an important kind of
inflection point now is it really that
much higher than six point nine five not
really but it is seen as a move by China
to devalue its currency in order to
fight back against the trumpian tariffs
the idea being if they devalue their
currency it makes it easier for them to
export product and harder for them to
import product that is one way of
fighting a tariff president Trump
immediately came back and suggested that
China was a currency manipulator he
treated out China drop the price of
their currency to an almost historic low
it's called currency manipulation
are you listening Federal Reserve this
is a major violation which will greatly
weaken China over time okay that last
part makes no sense if you believe that
China's devaluation of its currency
weakens China why are you calling on the
Federal Reserve to inflate the currency
that would presumably weak in the United
States Trump's understanding of
economics is flawed at best at best
when I say flawed at best I mean it's
really really terrible I mean Trump does
not understand international trade he
doesn't really understand inflation
he doesn't understand any of these
things now if you want to engage in a
trade war with China you actually do
have to make the case for why the United
States should be engaging in a trade war
with China now there are folks out there
like Niall Ferguson the historian who
have suggested that we should engage in
effectively a second cold war with China
that China is a growing power they've
been expending their resources on
military might in the South China Sea
they've been expanding into heretofore
unknown areas they have been cramming
down political tyranny on Hong Kong and
Trump by the way that would've been an
obvious point where Trump could have
said something right I mean the Hong
Kong protesters are are attempting to
resist Chinese intervention in Hong Kong
when Hong Kong was handed over to the
Chinese by the British in the 90s the
assumption was that Hong Kong would be
self-governing and that China would not
actually be in control of every aspect
of Hong Kong life that obviously has
turned out not to be true there are
these massive protests including like
one-fifth of the population out in the
streets in Hong Kong and Trump basically
repeated the language of the Chinese so
it's bewildering to me if you're gonna
make the case that China is a powerful
international enemy that they are
stealing our technology that they're
building their own 5g networks to
compete specifically with American 5-g
that they are using
as a weapon against the United States
that they are building up their military
resources that they're backing some of
the world's worst regimes including
North Korea that they're cracking down
on Democrats who would have been our
allies if they were independent in Hong
Kong if you want to make that case you
can certainly make that case and then
you have to make the case to the
American people that this is a war that
we can win that it will require
sacrifice from the American people you
have to be honest with the American
people about what this is going to do
honesty is requisite otherwise here's
what Americans see they see a bunch of
fluctuation and randomness in this trade
war and then they see their prices going
up in American businesses shutting down
because China has now declared on a
governmental level they're no longer
going to buy American agricultural
products you know who that's going to
hurt all the farmers in the rural areas
in the States Trump needs to win it's
gonna hurt Trump in Iowa it's gonna hurt
him in Wisconsin it's gonna hurt him
in Ohio in Michigan it's gonna hurt him
in a lot of the areas that are heavily
reliant on trade with China so if Trump
knows what he's doing he needs to
explain it to us because otherwise how
do you expect the American people to
take the sacrifice you are asking of
them Trump announced last week the
United States would impose a 10% tariff
on 300 billion dollars worth of Chinese
imports the tariff will take effect on
September 1st Trump's announcement came
after Chinese and US officials discussed
trade earlier this week as the two
countries tried to restart talks from
tweeted out this morning that the
Chinese are gonna come in September and
we're gonna try to restart those talks
and get these tariffs over with
everybody is deeply fearful that China's
devaluation of its currency is the
precursor to something else which is as
everybody rushes into the bond market to
buy bonds and as the yields go down that
China actually forces the yields back up
by selling off American bonds on the
open market Stephen Moore who's an
economic adviser to President Trump
Stephen Moore came out he said I think
we may have miscalculated here on
exactly what the Chinese are willing to
do well yes because they're a
dictatorship they don't care about their
own people yes the living standards have
been rising in China but China has an
alternative solution if people start to
get too uppity with them and that is
kill them or gulag right China is a
tyranny lest we forget
for all the talk about them being
friendly and wonderful Xi Jinping the
president of China is a dictator who
just reinstalled himself effectively for
life nonetheless you know Trump has
declared China currency
again if you want the Cold War you got
to explain why we're doing it
you do need to explain it and you can
make that case
China isn't a Farias actors I've said
repeatedly on the world stage they are a
geopolitical threat to the United States
probably America's top two you a
political threat okay but you actually
have to make that case and when you say
that they're a currency manipulator by
the way even that is not particularly
unclear the fact is that they were
artificially deflating their currency
for years now it's pretty obvious that
the devaluation that has happened is
honestly kind of a result of the tariffs
themselves when you tariff other
countries what you end up doing is
immediately increasing the value of your
own currency and devaluing other
currencies why well because there are
fewer American dollars in circulation
which means that the value of American
dollars goes up because there are fewer
of them in general international
circulation so it's not particularly
clear that China actually was involved
in currency manipulation this time it is
clear that China is willing to fight
this trade war nonetheless Trump thinks
that being tough on China is going to
work because it worked with Mexico now
maybe that's true maybe it's not true
because the Mexican government is
actually an extraordinarily weak
government and the Mexican government is
so weak that it's in many ways subjects
to the whims of Mexican drug cartels the
Chinese government is incredibly strong
so strong that can keep a billion people
in under the under the auspices of an
absolute Tyranny according to the
Washington Post Trump is increasingly
acting based on his own intuition and
analysis not the advice of aides in the
increasingly fraught trade war with
China
five people briefed on the action said
shattering a more cautious process that
had yielded few positive results so far
the Treasury Department's formal
announcement that a hit labeled China
currency manipulator him six hours after
Trump dated himself on social media the
people describing the White House
process spoke on condition of anonymity
of course they said White House
officials were now expecting a long
drawn-out battle with Chinese leaders
even though Trump is acutely tuned in to
stock market fluctuations but Trump is
convinced that the Chinese economy is
suffering more than the US economy from
the conflict now that's true the Chinese
economy is suffering more than the US
economy the difference is that Trump can
get voted out in 2020 Xi Jinping is
going to be there for as long as you
live Trump apparently also has felt
validated that his hardball threats in
other circumstances including a recent
tangle with Mexico over border security
seem to get at least some
results even if there even if they
scared investors in the short-term this
is left aids many of whom have preferred
for the president to be more patient to
scramble to complete directives issued
by President Trump stocks have been
plunging as Trump and China have
escalated the trade war some analysts
are fearing an escalated us-china
currency war as well not just a trade
war so a two-front war a currency war of
devaluation and a trade war trying to
allow the value of its tightly
controlled currency according to the
post to fall to an 11-year low on Monday
I moved that threatens to hurt American
producers by making their products more
expensive for Chinese customers the
Treasury Department then called China
currency manipulator what they could go
to the World Trade Organization by the
way and file a complaint you don't only
have to do this in a bilateral process
that's where Prasad professor afraid it
at Cornell said it could get very
serious if trade tensions between China
and the United States morph into a
currency war this could lead the United
States to essentially shut down all
imports from China some advisors some
economic advisors a strategist named
Masanori Takata / Namara he says we
could see a major market sell-off in the
wake of all of this Nomura says there
will be that they are warning the next
sell-off could resemble a crisis level
plunge like the one that followed the
Lehman Brothers collapse and most people
are predicting just a stock market
correction down 10 percent and maybe a
slight pullback in the stock market
Nomura is basing its view on data
showing hedge funds fleeing the market
and said more are set to exit when their
algorithms are triggered by rising
volatility remember we have an election
just a year and a half away China has
every interest in creating chaos in the
American markets so they can get a
Democrat in there and the same thing has
been true with Iran which is why they
are creating more chaos presumably with
the promise that if a Democrat gets in
there then they back off of all of that
this is where a strong communications
policy would be a very useful thing
right this is where President Trump
coming out and giving a speech on
exactly what he's doing with China would
be useful the American people deserve to
know otherwise it just feels like chaos
and that cast is gonna come out of
people's pockets okay time for a quick
thing I like and then a quick thing that
I hate and will get out of here so
things that I like speaking of Cold
War's both in the United States and
outside the United States there's a new
translation of a work that was
and under Stalin and therefore repeats a
lot of Stalinist tropes but is really
kind of a fascinating window into how
the censorship process worked in the
USSR
it's called Stalingrad the author's name
man in vasily grossman Grossman was but
persecuted and praised by the Stalin
regime he's more famous for another work
a life and fate which is quite an
amazing work that does concern the
Stalin years it was written after Stalin
was dead but Stalingrad which just came
out in a new translation by Robert
Chandler and Elizabeth Chandler is a
great window into how the Russians
viewed themselves in the middle of the
Battle of Stalingrad it obviously is
extraordinarily praiseworthy towards
Stalin and for the Stalinist regime
which is hard to read if you know the
truth about Stalin but the sort of
legacy of Stalingrad was the defining
moment in the mentality of a lot of
Russians it continues to be if you read
a book called secondhand time which is a
fantastic compendium of how Russians
think about themselves by a Nobel Prize
winner in literature the the kind of
mythos the myth making is very obvious
in this book Stalingrad by vasily
grossman it is a really well-written
book you can go check it out right now
it is it's a very long book it's sort of
Tolstoy asked in its approach but it's
worth the read okay um let's see
things that I hate well breaking news
things that I hate the New York Times
has admitted that their original
headline was a bad headline so Trump
urges unity versus racism apparently was
a bad headline the editor of the New
York Times has now backed down
completely he acknowledged that his
newspaper messed up with the front page
headline over its lead story they say it
was a mistake that prompted is according
to The Daily Beast it was a mistake that
prompted all sorts of consternation
widespread criticism from high-profile
Trump detractors once images of the
papers front page surfaced online on
Monday night it also provoked attacks on
the Times political coverage generally
even vows to cancel subscriptions but
Kent texted The Daily Beast it was
written on headline when it was passed
along for approval we all saw it was a
bad headline and changed it pretty
quickly
of course near a tan and the president
of the Center for American Progress
which is a leftist think-tank was
typical of The Times army of critics
implying the paper had caved in
Trump's constant attacks on the news
media no actually they caved in to your
attacks on the news media so it's very
bad for Trump to attack the press it's
very good for the left to attack the
press obviously and by the way earns
better results apparently so that's
exciting stuff in case you didn't know
the New York Times hates Trump in case
you didn't know the New York Times is
happy to pare it all the leftist talking
points all you have to do is take a look
at their editorial page but now that has
infused every aspect of their media
coverage to the point where they can be
bullied by the left into retracting
their own media coverage other things
that I hate today
it's actually a thing that I like
because I like reality but as it turns
out raising the minimum wage in New York
City leads people to cut hours and jobs
shocker according to The Wall Street
Journal more than six months after the
$15 minimum wage went into effect in New
York City business leaders and owners
say the increased labor costs have
forced them to cut staff eliminate work
shifts and raise prices many business
owners say these changes were unintended
consequences of the new minimum wage
which took effect at the beginning of
the year yeah you think
shocker it turns out that when you make
policy with your gut instead of your
brain it has unintended consequences I
can't believe it
not that every single study that has
ever examined minimum wage has
effectively found that there is not some
giant Bank full of Scrooge McDuck money
that employers are swimming around in
and holding back from their employees
and that increasing minimum wage
inevitably means cutting hours and
cutting jobs not that that is the most
common finding in economics but it's
pretty common it's a pretty common
finding in economics you mean that if
you force me to pay my employees more
I'll force them to work less or fire
them I can't believe it
shocker I guess we're all supposed to be
surprised by all of this so well done
once again city of New York driving
business out there as fast as humanly
possible just very solid stuff already
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right